any other
questions yeah I uh I hopped on a Muslim
stream maybe last week and I heard
someone talk about um how how can how
can
uh Paul preach New Testament about the
atoning sacrifice when he uh took the
Nazarite vow in Acts
18:18 um that argument yeah acts 1818
what do you do with acts 21:26 and
24:17 where Paul End paying the high
priest to offer up the sacrifices for
the men who had taken a Nazarite vow
under the suggestion of James and Paul
says that one of the reasons why he came
to Jerusalem was to offer sacrifices in
the
temple it's not only acts 1818 in fact
so people can understand what we're
talking about do you have their Bible
with you uh I have a Google sadly yeah
well it's all right if you can open up
get get to your Bible because I'm G to
have you read this because this is such
a dumb argument man these Muslims
they're so
desperate so go to acts 18:18 here guys
the question let me repeat the question
that he's telling you Paul who preached
that the blood of Jesus Christ is what
cleanses and
atones is seen the Nazarite Vow where he
would not put a razor to his head and at
the Fulfillment of The Vow he would have
to shave and offer
sacrifices you know burnt sacrifice
right sin
offering peace offering number 614 why
is he still having priest offer animal
sacrifices if as he claimed the blood of
Jesus is what cleanses you not animal
sacrifices that's acts 1818 so if you
open it read that for me yes Acts
1818 Paul stayed on in Corinth for some
time then he left the brothers and
sisters and sailed to Syria
AC accompanied by Priscilla and Aquilla
before he sailed he had his hair cut off
at uh K
Tre because of a vow he had taken so sh
that's an azerite shave your okay that
means he would then paav to observe
animal sacrifices now jump to acts 21
open up Acts 21 when you do you're going
to read 23 to 26
okay now James the so-called brother of
the Lord and the Elders of Jerusalem are
telling Paul just give you the context
are telling Paul look there are Jews who
are zealous for the law and they're
Believers in Jesus Christ they have
heard you Paul if you read from 20 down
it says they have heard that you Paul
teach the Jews living among the Gentiles
diaspora they don't have to circumcise
their children and ignore the cuss of
Moses they're going to hear that you're
here and that's going to cause trouble
now to show them there is no truth to
that rumor that you've been slandered
and lied because you don't teach Jews
notice ethnic Jews living among the
Gentiles you don't teach Jews not to get
circumcised or keep the custom Moses
because that's true Paul was talking
about Gentiles not Jews here's what
you're going to do acts 2123 to
26 therefore do what we tell you we have
four men who have made a vow
take these men purify yourself along
with them and pay for them to get their
heads shaved then everyone will know
that what they were told about you
amounts to nothing but that you yourself
are also careful about observing the law
with regard to the Gentiles who have
believed we have written a letter
containing our decision that they should
keep themselves from food sacrifice to
Idols from blood and from what is
strangled and from sexual
immorality so the next day Paul took the
men having purified himself along with
them and entered the temple announcing
the completion of the purification days
when the offering would be made for each
for each of them offering that's the
burnt offering sinin offering right and
peace offering 614 so notice Paul and
the other Jews are still having the
priest offer animal sacrifices in
fulfillment of certain Oaths in
Conformity to the law right right yes
now go to see what Paul says one of the
reasons why he came to Jerusalem acts
24:17 all right acts
24:17 after many years I came to bring
charitable gifts and offerings to my
people after many years he did
what bring charitable gifts and
offerings to my people the word
offerings means animal sacrifices in the
temple that's why he came to Jerusalem
so here are three cases where Paul and
the other
Jews are actually observing animal
sacrifices that are being performed in
the temple by the priests as long as the
temple is standing so does that
contradict Paul says no remember you
don't derive your theology from your own
opinion you derive your theology from
the books of the New Testament right yes
since Paul says it's the blood of Jesus
Christ that cleanses and atones and
Hebrews 10:4 we're told in Hebrews 10 if
you read verse four it says the blood of
bulls and goats do not remove sin
because if they did would they need to
be
repeated you understand the logic of the
author of Hebrews in chapter 10
specifically verse
four what is he saying go ahead yeah if
they were if if they really did remove
sins would it need to be repeated that's
the point in other words the fact that
you're repeating it God was showing you
the fact that they had to keep repeating
the sacrifices day in and day out meant
that these sacrifices could not remove
your sin from God's
sight because if they did you wouldn't
need to repeat them like the day of
atonement and the morning and evening
sacrifices right right so what they did
was they provided a temporary covering
over of your sin so yet you can be under
the grace of God and his mercy and he
doesn't consume you in his wrath until
the f fulfillment comes Jesus Christ who
alone perfects and takes away your sin
and satisfies God completely where God
is at peace with you because of Christ
and that's Hebrews 10:10 and
right by one sacrifice he has perfected
forever those who are being Sanctified
Hebrews 10:14
right yeah and Hebrews 10:10 says by
that will he has s
Sanctified all those by the offering of
his body okay so then let's put it
together Paul knows this the apostles
know this so are they observing animal
sacrifices to show Fidelity to the law
that they do honor Moses and his law
being from God and secondly now they
observe these sacrifices with the proper
attitude these sacrifices do not take
away sin they provided a temporary
covering but they were a shadow of
something greater Jesus Christ so we
observe them not because they take away
our sin but to show our thankfulness and
Fidelity to the law that God gave Moses
and use that as a stepping stone to tell
the Jews these sacrifices the fact that
you're repeating them shows they don't
do the job of removing your sin right
yeah because they're pointing someone
greater who does who Jesus
Christ so chosing Fidelity to the god of
Moses that's the same God revealed in
Christ and and also using that as an
opportunity to point people to Christ
hey what do you think these sacrifices
point to the suffering servant of Isaiah
53 so where's the
problem if they didn't have a problem
why should you have a problem unless
your theology is different from
theirs you want me there because I can't
hear you yeah yeah I hear you I guess
maybe uh I just I guess when I heard it
from a Muslim and you know with the
institution of the New Covenant right
it's kind of It kind of comes and goes
right when Christ gives the Eucharist he
says this is the blood of my new
covenant so this is before where did you
get that the New Covenant was
established by the same writers that
told you the Jews who follow Jesus so
you see what you're doing you're
determining what the New Covenant
entails instead of deriving what it
entails from the very writers who told
you about the New
Covenant can't have your cake and eat it
too how do you know anything about the
New Covenant and its
fulfillment how do you know anything
about it where do you get that
information from
it would it would be uh from
the from from the Holy Spirit guiding uh
I i' say through the church to give the
proper understanding you find that
information in the New Testament you
mean the same New Testament where you're
told the same Apostles and disciples
Guided by the spirit had no problem
offering animal sacrifices because they
didn't see it as being incompatible with
the proclamation that Jesus instituted
the New
Covenant yeah same place so then why do
you have a Pro of
denen uh it it's just because it was the
first time I heard of it and I was C off
guard a rhetorical questions I'm in
other words and asking the question you
got the answer right yeah because the
same Luke who wrote acts who told you
that Paul and the other Apostles and
their disciples who are Jews ethnically
who were in Jerusalem contined to over
animal sacrifices is the same Luke who
wrote in Luke 22:9 to 20 the words of
Our Lord this cup is the New Covenant
shed in my
blood so he didn't have a problem Paul
didn't have a problem James didn't have
a problem Peter didn't have a problem
and they're the ones who are telling you
what the New Covenant is and entails so
why should I have a problem when my
theology comes from them I don't impose
my theology on them I derive my theology
from them right see the
point yeah yeah and this is the problem
with Christians today they've already
assumed certain things
and assume certain definitions and then
when they go back to the Bible and see
the Bible doesn't agree with their
definition understanding then they
create a problem when there was none the
problem was with your understanding not
with what the New Testament
teaches yeah exactly true yeah is a
failure on my end yeah and it's not you
this is something because when I'm
taught a certain thing and I'm confront
these passages the first thing is shock
wow they didn't because the church is
poorly catechized in the West
why did I why do you think I encourage
you go teach your Christian brother
sister Jesus says love one another as I
have loved you and love your neighbor as
yourself do unto others as you'd have
them do unto you well if you love your
neighbor as yourself and you want to
know the faith and be taught it properly
then do that to them you go and teach
them Apostles Creed so they don't get
caught off guard by Bible perverts and
butcher whose purpose is to destroy your
faith in
scripture yeah right
yeah so that answer the question yeah
yeah it did it really helped me a lot
thank you brother praise God brother
it's my pleasure to serve people who are
honest and sincere it's a great joy
because I see the spirit working and
causing people to love Jesus more and
appreciate his word more thoroughly so
now you take this and share it with your
church brother don't leave them in dark
because there are a lot of Christians
who are confused and Saints waiting to
put a Muslim or Jo witness in their path
to get them to lose their
way yeah thank you I appreciate any
other questions no that's all I have